Jenny is with us in Nashville hi Jenny
how are you I'm good how are you better
than I deserve what's up well I lost my
home a couple of years ago my son talked
me into putting it up for a lung for a
business and he was starting and he went
bankruptcy well he told me that not to
worry about it that he was going to take
care of me but he talked me into not
going to the court hearing and then then
V&E told me I don't know you anything up
i bob bankrupt feeling that it was
$50,000 but it was enough to move my
home is there anything we can do
I'm sorry oh well not only lose your
home but breaks your heart to done it
yes yes he had just come back from Iraq
so he had my heart but um he did he did
go to the bank my husband kept after him
and he went to the bank and he had he
had a hat oh goodness he had a paper
shot that he would that he did own
$50,000 that he would pay $600 a month
and he did pay that for a couple of
months that was before the bankruptcy or
after the bankruptcy that was after the
bankruptcy um but then he's not paying
of course no it doesn't matter much
because you lost your house already
right yes I mean did you get sued from
that or did you just take it yes fed to
my credit okay so they're still coming
after you well no the bank told me that
they would not come after me for that
they were going to just write it off but
then they ended up turning against my
credit even though they didn't come
after me for the bank who the balance
but see my bank my house was paid off
until I got this loan for my son and so
where have you guys been living since
the foreclosure uh in an apartment in
being we bought another house okay so
you got another home
um well we're paying for another home
yeah yeah but well the sad answer to
your question is there's nothing to be
done it's a really really expensive and
heartbreaking lesson to not pledge your
home for a business certainly not pledge
it for a business for someone else ever
it's a heartbreaking lesson and then the
way that you've not been he's not been
honorable afterwards is even more
heartbreaking but it just says okay we
don't lend money to relatives because
when they don't pay it back it leaves a
it leaves a relationship that's bad
because it doesn't matter how many years
go by Thanksgiving dinners never going
to taste the same now it's true because
of this and so because you're always
going to be thinking you he owes you
this he's never going to pay it
basically my husband moves his get bad
but the fact that he went back to the
bank and uh you can tell you that the
problem is a piece of paper does not
make someone behave unless you take them
to court and the judge makes them behave
that's the only thing it's not a magical
thing that he said you had this magical
piece of paper you can wave over his
head and suddenly he grows character
he's not he's not got character that's
the problem
and so I mean in a moment of you know
being badgered by his dad or whatever he
signed it but he's not done anything
with it so now you're left with you
you're left with two choices forget it
tear it up and forget it that's one
choice or sue him okay that's the other
choice dad and he wants to share in the
park so um what it how old are you - I'm
52 and your husband he's 57 and what's
your household income today um we're
both disabled and unemployed error so is
this for a night just I think it's about
2,300 for a month um
I don't think he's going to pay you do
you know no as a matter of fact his wife
said she was not paying um here's a
proposal okay there's three actually
only three possible options on the table
one is you sue him you're all using that
piece of paper you probably could win
and the only thing you could do then
would be to take a lien against his home
or garnish his wages or whatever that
pretty much ensures that your son is out
of your life for the rest of your life
doesn't it well he told me that he
doesn't like you like okay so you could
do that and that would pretty much put
cement on top of that then okay the
second thing you could do is you can do
what you're doing right now which is
nothing and stay mad all the time well
hurt and ma'am Merton matters madam
pardon matter best friends they run
around together okay and the third the
third thing you could do would be to
tear the note up and forgive it okay and
I don't know that that's going to do him
any good
but I think it might set you and your
husband free well we need to be set free
yeah and so my advice were you coming to
me to coach me would be and it'd be
hardest for your husband probably harder
than for you um but that you guys
together on your knees pray about this
and ask God to give you the strength to
completely let this go and I think a
piece will flood both of your souls and
I would tear it up and I would write him
and his wife a letter and I wouldn't say
one mean thing in the letter although
there's a lot of mean things that would
be fair to say I'm kind I'm kind of mad
at your son and I don't even know him so
it would be pretty pretty easy to say
some mean things okay but instead I
would just say this note and this debt
is completely forgiven and you are
forgiven that's all I would say and sign
your names and put that P torn-up note
in an envelope and mail it to him and I
would go on with my life with a smile
okay and this is one of those painful
horrible things that's happened that we
all go past because as long as you keep
carrying this around
it's bothering you a lot mourners
bothering him oh yes I believe that and
if I thought suing him would change him
into a good man I'd sue his butt and
there might be some cases I might sue
him anyway but in your case just talking
to you with your sweet broken heart and
I just think there's more benefit than
the money you're not going to get anyway
by letting it go that's just something
to think about y'all talk about and
decide if you want to do that or not but
I think that's probably the best
proposal of the three that's on the
table sue him get what you can get and
deal with that continue to stay mad are
completely forgiving those are really
your only three options here